hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen in today's edition of
what i in a day youtuber reviews i'm
going to be taking a look at greg
ducette now greg is a popular fitness
influencer and coach here on youtube
who creates content surrounding
reviewing other youtubers diets and
fitness regimes
also his personal diet tips and tricks
for weight loss
as well as the odd video on what he eats
in a day to stay
shredded he has a master's degree in
kinesiology and is part of the
bodybuilding and powerlifting community
so right off the bat i just want to flag
that this guy's diet is in no way going
to be
recommended or typical for the average
person
and what competitive weight lifters eat
to stay at such a low body fat
percentage
is generally not recommended for the
average woman or man
he himself has commented that he is not
a registered dietitian
and has even said don't listen to me
this is just what i do kind of thing
but like i always say if you're putting
information
out there you do have to take
responsibility for it
now i will say he doesn't upload a ton
of what i in a day videos
and it does seem like whenever he does
there while he is
cutting or trying to drop his body fat
percentage
however he does state in these videos
that the foods that he eats on season
are pretty much the same as what he eats
off season but that his caloric
intake would basically just increase so
if he eats around 2 500 to 3 000
calories
on season he says he eats around 3 500
calories
off season greg has also gained a lot of
popularity over
his very blunt diet advice which some
viewers
may perceive as offensive i know it was
even hard for me to get through some of
this content
so if you feel that you will be
triggered by this
please feel free to skip over this video
i also just want to point out that while
a lot of you begged for this video some
also warned me that he's probably going
to attack me for this
but here i go anyway because i
apparently love you all
a lot also as you know i am not a sports
dietitian specialist
so i did consult with a few of my sports
rd colleagues for this video
so if you're interested i will leave
some of their names below so that you
can reach out to them
if you're looking for some one-on-one
coaching with an rd
now before we jump into this review i
want to start with my general disclaimer
that the information in this video is
for entertainment and educational
purposes only
and you should always seek out the help
of a registered dietitian
or medical professional for your unique
case
also don't forget to subscribe and ring
the little bell so that you
never miss a video all right let's meet
greg
six out of seven days it's the same
thing it's six french toast
now you might ask well what did you eat
in the off season well i had seven
french toast so i was eating more
and i just like to really soak in the
the whatever you call it the egg white
stuff here into the bread
and so there's just egg whites and um
cinnamon and then the sugar twin and
what's it called there that black stuff
that you um
vanilla vanilla extract it's not gonna
kill me you guys are eating rice which
is worse so who cares
all right so this is the finished
product this is what six french toast
looks like
with the syrup a green shake
okay so for his first meal greg is
having six slices of french toast made
with white bread
egg whites and sweetener served up with
some diet
maple syrup and a green shake on the
side
now i'm not 100 sure but it does look
like this is kind of like a green powder
thing mixed with some water in the shake
and i can already tell that greg opts
for mainly a lot of diet products from
the sweetener to the diet syrup and that
does align with the fact that he is
dieting for a weightlifting show however
he
also mentions that he eats basically the
same thing off season
just more of it so i am thinking that he
may actually
choose these sugar-free diet foods
year-round
by the way if you are interested in
learning more about sweeteners and
health
you can check out my video right here as
for his meal choices
i mean first off i love me some french
toast
though when i make it it doesn't usually
look like that
but i would ultimately love to see just
a little bit more variety
in this meal maybe you know throwing in
some sauteed vegetables instead of the
powdered green shake
or some fruit and yogurt on the side
that would totally
boost up the balance and nutrient
content of this meal
also just for the general public you
know there's no harm in cooking with
egg yolks though i am assuming he's
opting for just the weight since they do
have
negligible calories without the fat
while still offering
lots of protein he also cooks with spray
oil so
all this together you know it's pretty
obvious that his prep
plan is probably pretty low fat
and according to my colleagues this is
pretty
typical for show prep while cutting as
fat
is calorie dense so a lot of athletes
will aim to get the most protein and
fiber
and volume out of their food for the
least amount of calories
to stave off hunger while maintaining
muscle mass
but if this were a normal or off-season
diet
i would definitely recommend boosting
the fat content of this meal you know
maybe by sprinkling it with some flax
seed
or adding some full fat yogurt on top
now another thing i want to flag here is
his bread
choice we've got white bread here now i
am totally on board with people choosing
a variety
of grains and having white bread mixed
into a balanced diet
is totally cool in my books my personal
opinion though
is that this french toast would
definitely be more filling
and satiating for greg if it was made
with a
whole grain bread since that would offer
a little bit more fiber and protein
it sometimes does make sense to choose
more refined carbs like white breads
around your workout
so that the fiber doesn't interfere with
the digestion or the uptake of protein
or carbs for energy
but honestly the impact of this is
typically negligible
and since he's not training right now
the whole grain bread would definitely
be
a more satiating choice for a low
caloric
load this might just be his preference
of course which is
totally fine as well also i watched
another video where greg talks about why
race is worse than white bread and his
rationale was simply that
bread has three grams more protein and
one gram more fiber
than rice per 200 calorie portion
to me these are virtually
interchangeable to be honest as
i don't think an extra 3 grams of
protein in greg's day is
going to make or break his prep but
i too would prefer bread in the morning
so greg
you do you anyways let's move on to
lunch
now we're up to peas chicken
and no rice popcorn
i'm telling you i don't eat rice at the
end of a show prep i switch to popcorn
because
that for 225 calories
compared to that much rice just seems so
much more appealing plus this is
way more fiber more protein and it
tastes way better so how can you go
wrong really
so there's my veggies chicken and
popcorn and there you go meal too
all right so for this meal we are seeing
a fairly good
balanced and easy meal we have about
half of the plate filled with peas
protein from the chicken breast and
starch from
the popcorn though again greg rice is
not the
enemy however i totally do get what he's
saying
if i was dieting i would also want to
eat as much volume as i could
to feel more satisfied though for your
average non-bodybuilder
adding in some healthy fats would
definitely help accomplish that satiety
factor as well
now back to greg's unique case evidence
does suggest that fitness competitors
should ideally be coached
to consume between 15 to 30 percent of
their calories from fat
in those two to four months before a
show
women will of course be on the higher
end and men on the lower end
but regardless this is slightly below
the
general recommendation of 20 to 35
of your calories from fat one of my
colleagues suggested
to not ever go below 0.5 grams
per kilogram of body weight which is
just another way that you could
measure this now because fat plays such
a crucial role in hormone production
which is including testosterone a key
component for maintaining muscle mass
cutting fat below 15 is generally
not recommended for bodybuilders in fact
one study actually did find a modest but
significant reduction in testosterone
when fat intake was cut from 40 to 20
signaling that having an adequate fat
intake
is still crucial during the cutting
phase
as for his analysis of rice to popcorn
he
is right that calorie for calorie air
popped popcorn offers
more fiber and just a little less
protein than
something like brown rice would however
brown rice is
also a rich source of other nutrients
that are not found in smart pop so
things like
b vitamins magnesium phosphorus
manganese and selenium
it's also lower in salt so if we're
looking at the nutrient profile
brown rice while less voluminous still
has
a lot of important nutrition benefits
also
here's a little fun factoid you can
reduce the digestible starch content in
rice
through a process called starch
retrogradation
now starch retrogradation is a process
that takes place
in certain starchy foods like rice after
they have
been cooled down following cooking
so upon being cooled the rice forms new
structures that are more
digestion resistant meaning they contain
less available carbohydrates for our
body to digest and absorb
the longer the storage time the more
retrogradation
that actually can take place one study
even found
that depending on the cooking methods
and variety of rice
resistant starches could be increased by
10 times
and could cut the calories in the rice
by around 50 to 60 percent
their particular method for cooking and
cooling process
involves boiling water with a teaspoon
of coconut oil and then adding the rice
and letting it simmer for about 40
minutes or
boiling it for 20 to 25 minutes and then
refrigerating it
for 12 hours the way the researchers
explained this change
is that the fat from the coconut oil
entered into the rice grains
changing their structure and making them
more resistant to our own digestive
enzymes
aka digestive resistant i did a whole
blog post on this process so
if you are interested in reading more
definitely check it out
i'm going to leave a link below in the
description
so long story short if greg is looking
for ways to include rice in his diet if
he even likes it
the cooking and cooling process could be
a great way to do that
since he could technically increase his
portion size and consume the same
amount of calories just saying anyways i
also want to note that i see he's
putting a little sugar-free ketchup on
the side of his meal which
has sucralose added into it which is
another artificial sweetener so
with the sweeteners french toast and the
diet syrup
it's looking like he actually takes in
quite a lot of artificial sweeteners to
cut
calories in prep all in all though
while this meal looks a little
uninspired and
lacks the fat factor for satiety and
satisfaction
which again i know is part of greg's
plan for cutting
it is an otherwise fairly balanced meal
moving on let's take a look at what greg
has for his mid-afternoon snack
or first dinner whichever way you want
to look at it
what i have is a p28 wrap which
is this which i eat every day i always
eat at least one kind of wrap
it's got chicken and all kinds of sauces
some flax seeds and this is basically
where i get my fat from is like
salad dressing some like mustard
10 calorie barbecue sauce and then
as you can see i just like make the
biggest
wrap in the world okay so
yum i mean this meal looks really
delicious
we're getting a good dose of protein
from the protein enriched wrap
and the chicken we've got some healthy
fats from the flax though i'm not really
sure
how much he used on that but we've got
tons of fiber from
all of those veggies and i love the idea
of
putting down the romaine before stuffing
your wrap i mean i'm totally gonna
steal that hack interestingly greg
mentions that he gets his fats from the
salad dressings
but from what i can tell all of those
are kind of like low fat or
diet options so again i get that for him
it's all about caloric density in prep
and fats are calorically dense but
speaking from a nutritional
balance perspective for the average man
or woman who is active we could
definitely
up the fat now at one point when greg is
talking about this meal
he points out that you will not get fat
eating this stuff
which for him is probably not untrue
considering the caloric deficit that he
is in but what we know about dieting
is that when people force themselves
into this sort of deficit
and follow really strict food rules the
most
common outcome is that they end up
breaking
and binging on those foods that were not
allowed
so while you may not get fat eating
these foods you might gain weight in the
long run
as a result of the restrict binge cycle
in fact
it's not uncommon for fitness
competitors to weight cycle
really drastically after a show when
they go off a diet
partially because of metabolic or
hormonal declines
but also because of the psychological
tool
i have a whole video covering some of
these common risks of fitness
competitors
that you can check out right here but
anyways
let's take a look at his second dinner
all right i've finished training so
um meal four is on the go i finished a
while ago
you don't have to eat right after the
gym there's no proof or anything that
you need to do that
it's just not important it's only been
whatever hours so
um anyway okay so before we get into the
meal i just want to briefly
touch on that comment because there is
actually some scientific evidence to
support that
eating shortly after exercise will help
the body better recover
and benefit from the training or
weightlifting one study
published in 2013 concluded that
consuming protein and carbohydrates
immediately within 45 minutes after an
extreme
bout of exercise can increase the rate
of glycogen
storage in the muscle reduce muscle
damage
increase the breakdown and use of
protein in the body
as well as speed up recovery from the
exercise
meanwhile a more recent study from 2017
refuted the narrow post exercise window
theory
but only if there was a pre-workout meal
consumed within a few hours prior to the
workout
their theory is that there is a window
around training
both before and after of around four to
six hours where nutrients
should be consumed therefore if a
pre-workout meal was consumed within
two hours before training then a
post-workout meal
up to three hours after would still be
beneficial for recovery and muscle
growth
however if training was done fasted then
the authors
still did suggest a post-workout meal
immediately
to soon after completion of the exercise
another coinciding study also done in
2017
supported the fact that eating within
two hours after working out delivers the
best results
although they did note that eating as
soon as possible
is still the golden standard so when
i've consulted with sports dietitians
they all say that
yes new research suggests that the
window might not be
quite as narrow as we used to think but
they still do recommend eating as soon
as possible for optimal results
anyways let's take a look what greg ate
after his workout
right here and i can eat two to three of
these but i'm
dieting really hard now so i just kind
of cut back calories so i'm gonna have
two
it's about 450 calories in both okay for
the whole meal so it's not really a lot
and i have just good old
costco sliced chicken turkey stuff here
on one of them and then you know normal
chicken on the other
and then i just literally load up as
many of these vegetables as can possibly
fit
okay so same same but kind of different
i guess
um basically we're seeing lots of
veggies fiber
protein and not surprisingly not a lot
of fat
i will say however that for a
post-workout meal
that is actually okay and even preferred
the reason is that we want to get the
protein to our muscles
sooner than later and fat or fiber can
suddenly slow
this down so this is why i would have
liked to see
more fat earlier on in the day even
though again
i totally get that this may interfere
with his need to volume eat
these low calorie foods pre-show now
before his next meal in the video he
mentions that he usually has an
optional snack of either some smart pot
popcorn
a light yogurt ice cream bar or homemade
protein bar
which he didn't today because he is
pushing himself to get
super shredded yikes i know that greg
has been doing this for a
long time and he knows his body best
but for the average person opting to not
have a snack if you are actually hungry
will typically end in breaking diet and
risking
a massive binge let's take a look at his
last meal or snack of the day
it's casein protein and it's super thick
and it is
just under two liters
super thick casein protein
i've got strawberries in there okay so
here we have a protein ice cream which
actually looks really good um it
apparently has casein protein
strawberries sugar-free chocolate syrup
and i'm assuming some water
as it is kind of pretty liquid now the
walden farms syrup he uses
claims to be calorie free but is that
even possible
well the ingredients were things like
defatted cocoa powder
triple filtered water artificial colors
stabilizers like cellulose gum
and splenda so basically just a bunch of
additives
in a jar now defatted cocoa powder has
about
one tenth of the fat of real cocoa
powder but it's not actually calorie
free
so as i've mentioned before if a product
has less than
five calories per serving it can be
labeled as
calorie free but if you eat the whole
bottle
you are going to get some calories not
of course
as much as like normal chocolate syrup
but still
you will be adding calories plus
probably a trip to the toilet
as cellulose does tend to cause loose
bowels when consumed
in excess but i digress so let's get to
the big questions
in general is this way of eating
balanced
well let's dive into the facts here
folks both of these days
greg is eating about 2500 calories which
is far
lower than what he likely actually needs
which is probably an extra thousand
calories more or so
as for his macros he is ranging from
between
17 to 19 of his calories from fat
so as i mentioned before testosterone
levels can decline under
20 calories from fat but the main
recommendation is to
never dip below 15 which he did not
as for the calories i will say that for
most people
a thousand calories is a super extreme
deficit
this would mean losing two pounds per
week which
could risk competitors cutting into
their gains
and losing metabolic muscle mass my
sports dietitian colleagues suggested
that most competitors are looking at a
20 to 40 caloric deficit from their
baseline
and it's safest to not lose more than
0.5 to 1 percent of body weight per week
in any kind of normal situation two
pounds a week
would not be safe or sustainable as a
rate of weight loss
for most people even sticking to this
extreme of a deficit for a week would be
a
huge challenge that would very likely
backfire
but greg is a coach himself so i'm sure
he knows that this is not
meant to be sustained and his plan is
uniquely tailored
to how his body performs and responds to
dieting
now as i did some extra digging i did
find that greg has been
accused of using performance-enhancing
drugs in the media
as there has been multiple violations
related to smuggling
and distributing illegal anabolic
steroids in canada
whether he actually uses these drugs is
out for debate and i am
100 not accusing anyone of that
having said that anabolic steroids are
taken by a lot of elite bodybuilders to
increase muscle mass while reducing body
fat
despite having a significant caloric
deficit and low fat intake
which would normally negatively affect
testosterone
again not accusing here folks according
to my colleagues
this type of extreme low-fat diet and
caloric deficit
is not uncommon but i just wanted to
comment on the accusation because
i know there's going to be a lot of
flags about it in the comments
now obviously this is not balanced for
the average healthy individual
even one who's actively trying to lose
weight and lose fat
and even though i acknowledge that he is
cutting or trying to get shredded in
these videos
greg also mentions that he pretty much
eats this way
year-round just maybe some bigger
portions
so i do hope that he allows himself a
little bit more fat
and just more foods that he actually
likes the rest of the off-season
year i actually saw a video where he
shared his off-season grocery haul
and yeah it was pretty much all the same
stuff
finally i will just say that there are a
lot of artificially sweetened diet
products
in his diet i've already commented on
this ad nauseam in my video here
but like actual sugar and well like
anything else
there may be such thing as too much of a
good thing
i know greg's mentality on diet products
is no calories
no concerns but i'm not sure that we
have enough evidence to say that's the
case
now are there any problematic claims or
assumptions made by this channel
oh boy where do i even
start well number one i don't like that
he
explicitly promotes the under
consumption of healthy fats
time and time again we see greg refer to
fat as
a waste of calories which again i get
how it can seem this way when you're in
a thousand calorie deficit
and the calorie to volume ratio of every
tablespoon
of sugar-free syrup counts but the fact
is that we actually really need fats in
our diet
to promote overall health the fat that
we get from our diet especially those
healthy fats like omega-3s help us to
absorb fat soluble vitamins
as well as to promote our brain health
and functioning
dietary fat also helps to reduce
inflammation
and reduce joint pain which is something
that should be at the top of
any bodybuilder's priority list i do
worry that painting all fat so
aggressively
with a bad brush has real power to
promote some orthorexic tendencies
especially in his female viewers now
next is that he consistently promotes
the under consumption of
calories let's quickly watch this clip
the average woman eats 1800 calories a
day
the average man 2800 calories a day
that's what the average person is eating
in case you're just like
well i don't know it gives you a
ballpark idea of what kind of calorie
range people are eating
should you be eating that much no no you
shouldn't
1800 calories a day for women 2 800 for
men what does the average person look
like
the average person looks like poop
so if you want to look like poop chances
are
keep eating as much as you're eating
unless you're already awesome
unless you already look amazing unless
you're already a competitor
then this video is not for you this is
for the normal average
person the average person that maybe
they work out it just wants to look a
little bit better
i know i warned you about his less than
sensitive choice of words
but in this video he actually suggested
that the average person
looks like poop and that in order to
look above
average you're going to have to need to
eat less calories
than what's recommended but as a way to
generally talk about people
this is just not okay promoting a
constant state of
undernourishment and seemingly attaching
it
to a sense of morality is so against
everything i stand for and it's just so
problematic
considering most of the world will never
achieve
greg's physique even with extreme
dieting and restriction
in fact just moderately active females
and males
need 2 and 2 800 calories respectively
to sustain their health so promoting
under eating in order to
better ourselves is just unsafe
and not healthy at all now third is the
constant dichotomization of foods as
good
and bad and for this i do want to share
a quick
clip warning greg's delivery
is intense make smart and healthy
choices and eat good
good food oh there's no coats there's no
thing it's good food and bad food you're
spreading the wrong message
shut up a chocolate bar is bad
food an apple is good food you want to
argue with me all day
go ahead you're just being stupid wow
um okay so as we've covered in my
intuitive eating series
when we classify food into these
distinct categories
we give them moral value when we think
of a certain food as being bad
and ourselves as being bad for eating it
we
tend to obsessively want it more
this perpetuates a dangerous cycle of
under eating
and overeating and results in a really
unhealthy relationship with your body
and mind now the truth is i'm a
dietitian
there is no doubt in my mind that foods
are not
nutritionally equal but we can make them
morally equal by dropping this kind of
language
eating a cupcake does not make you a bad
person
and eating an apple does not make you
inherently a good person
this kind of language is at the root of
orthorexic eating patterns
and it really needs to stop
now number four is his assumption that
weight is a personal
choice and eventually you might be able
to go for a one hour walk
the way i can you might not be superman
running with perfect form you don't need
to you need to move your body and be
healthy
so don't use this time as an excuse
that exercise is a stress and i'm gonna
sit on the couch and eat a bunch of
chips
and say it's okay it is not okay
so okay as we briefly touched on before
greg seems to think that there is only
one reason
people can be overweight they eat too
much
and that makes it a personal choice
however we know that the whole picture
has
a lot more complex layers than that as i
mentioned before
while yes our weight may be influenced
by our diet of course
it is also largely determined by our
genetics the environment that we live
and work in
our microbiome our hormones certain
diseases and medications
and yes even restriction we know that
weight is the result of
so much more than calories in and
calories out so the law of
thermodynamics that greg
is referring to is just far too simple
to account for human experience
and weight fluctuations what he's
referring to is the law of physics where
energy
in this case calories cannot be created
or destroyed
therefore calories in equals calories
out
and if weight gain is occurring it would
simply come down
to too many calories in and not enough
out you know why this law shouldn't be
applied to
humans like it is machinery
because we unlike machines can have
irregular
insulin responses dysfunctional thyroids
fluctuating hormones
and or prescribed medications that
change how we store
and mobilize fat in our bodies this is
not even scratching the surface of the
social determinants of health
which we know also play a huge role
in some videos he even mentions that he
has
nothing against obese people but that he
just wants his viewers to be
the best versions of themselves and that
is great
but self-loathing and being miserable
eating foods that you don't like
and not eating enough food to meet your
body's basic needs
is not my definition of being the best
version
of yourself
okay last but not least
he's against intuitive eating and
self-compassion
even during times of a global pandemic
who's this time to freaking self-justify
that it's okay to get off your training
plan that it's okay to not exercise
then it's okay to order pizza every
night
you don't think my girlfriend orders
pizza every other day i think she's had
pizza four times the last three weeks
14 inch pizzas and 12 inch garlic
fingers last for two or three days
that's all i see
i had a z pieces a zero
it's a choice and you choose to do it or
not
and it's not a punishment to eat healthy
and exercise
it's not so this is his response to
stephanie buttermore's amazing video
on having self-compassion and patience
with yourself during these crazy
and stressful times of cover 19. he
instead believes that people should have
a
no excuse approach their diet plan and
never have any wiggle room or space for
gentle nutrition and intuition it was
honestly
really hard watching this response to
stephanie's video
because there are so many people out
there that are just
truly struggling with the stress of this
pandemic
and practicing self-compassion is a
great way
to cope and grow throughout this process
honestly overall this channel is just
not a supportive place for those people
who are looking to have a healthy
relationship with food
or their body in fact greg is a firm
believer
that you should not have a relationship
with food
he specifically has said and i quote
relationships are with people
not with food step one don't think of
yourself as having a relationship with
food
think of food as something that you eat
that sustains life
and that tastes good sometimes it's not
a relationship
stop using it as a friend food is
biologically
evolutionarily meant to be enjoyed if it
didn't
our ancestors wouldn't put their lives
at risk to get it and we wouldn't see it
be so
intrinsically intertwined with culture
celebrations
mourning religion and more no i am not
suggesting that food
should become our only emotional coping
mechanism
and friend but we do want to actively
aim to have
a morally neutral relationship with it
for overall health okay moving on folks
what can we take away from greg's
channel
that is positive well if you look hard
enough through greg's videos
and i did there are short moments that
have
some good takeaways i just find them to
either be
contradicted or overshadowed by his
delivery
and a lot of other messaging so here are
some good things that i think we could
maybe take away from his channel
so for one he isn't into fad diets or
cutting out
specific random foods i can appreciate
the hard work that goes into what greg
has achieved in his physique
and his athletic performance and i can
also appreciate that he does it
by bringing it back to basics it isn't
about food combining or
trying out an alkaline diet he also
doesn't seem to promote a lot of
pseudoscience popularized by the
wellness community
he's actually fairly evidence-based
calling on some research articles
throughout his videos
that pertain to muscle growth
maintenance and caloric needs for weight
loss
and while his tactics to lose weight may
be drastic
and potentially unhealthy they're not
scientifically
wrong now the other thing that i want to
mention is he actually shares that his
self-worth
shouldn't come from how you look there
was one clip that i found
where greg actually explicitly says that
your self-worth
should come from your accomplishments or
how good of a person that you are
not from how you look if greg truly
believes this
amazing i wish he would say it more
often
but i do think that this sentiment as
refreshing as it was to hear
is often overshadowed by his tough love
and flippant commentary bottom line
greg's channel promotes a
no excuse approach to dieting with lots
of weight
exclusive talk going on i am not even in
a larger body
and even i found it hard to get through
a lot of greg's videos as
our view on health and wellness clearly
does not align
i'm well aware that a lot of these elite
sports do require
very specific and often very strict
dietary manipulations
and i respect those who go down that
path
but i do worry that people will see
greg's obvious
physique accomplishments and think that
everybody needs to diet down to this
degree
this is just not sustainable or healthy
for the average person
and it does not promote i'm going to say
it greg a healthy
relationship with food the best thing
that we can wish on ourselves
is not necessarily to be shredded but to
be healthy
in body and mind end of story
well folks that is all for today's video
please i want to remind you
let's be kind in the comments both on my
video and
on any of greg's we want to keep this a
supportive place
if you liked it be sure to give me the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
who you would like to see me review next
until then subscribe to the channel and
i will see you next time on abby's
kitchen
[Music]
bye
you